i'm alvin i'm a tasty producer and i
made a giant 30 pound burger it was kind
of a crazy thing because it required me
to think about all the components such
as the bun the burger and the cheese and
first thing i did was think about how do
i tackle the bun i settled on a pretty
standard brioche recipe but the tricky
thing was that we had to multiply it by
like 10. essentially just added a lot of
eggs butter and water into a mixing bowl
this was actually multiplied so much
that it was supposed to make like a
giant brioche loaf and usually with
brioche you cut it up and then you eat
it but for this one you just roll it up
and you bake it off as the whole thing
it was actually really fun i've never
made brioche before so this is a cool
experience but what was super awesome
about this one was that i was able to
just play with the dough it was just so
soft it was super elastic and i just
wanted to kind of hold it forever
because it was like holding a newborn
baby and i think when my kid grows up i
don't want him to grow up because i
wanted to feel like that for a long time
i expected it to expand a lot and we
just kind of diy this foil ring and kind
of had that the size of the hamburger
bun so it was kind of nice to have like
a finished almost biscuit-like looking
brioche so after cutting in half it was
pretty awesome we buttered it just
because i don't think you want a burger
that doesn't have a toasted bun and then
we approached the meat so the meat was
pretty interesting because it was
essentially two giant patties i didn't
want to do one super thick patty because
i don't think you can really eat it and
i really was inspired by a lot of the
smash burger style burgers we've seen
out there so i wanted to do two thin
patties and that required me to pretty
much go to the grocery store and go to
the ground beef section and essentially
clean it out definitely got a lot of
weird looks some old lady was super nice
was really cute she was like oh young
man you must be a growing boy and i was
like uh yeah yeah sure and she was like
oh i have a son and he used to eat just
like you and i was like if he ate like
this
i i'm a little worried about that so you
know it could have been pretty easy to
just throw a bunch of cheese slices on
the burger you know i didn't really want
to play that game i kind of mixed
together you know american cheese slices
chopped it up mixed it with another
cheese that i really like which is
cheddar cause i wanted the flavor and i
think cheddar tastes really good so i
melted them together and kind of created
like this cheese concoction mixture
which was really satisfying by the way
but i was like cutting cheese for like
20 minutes because there's so much
cheese that went into this it was like
40 blocks after that just made you know
kind of
i was like hey if you spread it on a
tray in a square shape and you trim it
will you end up with a swerve cheese we
got a nice firm american slice i was
like oh wow this actually turned out
pretty well assembly was really tricky
because usually when you're assembling a
burger you don't think about how heavy
everything is it was like three whole
tomatoes and two containers of lettuce
to fill that burger up it was just a lot
of stuff all around i pretty much only
had one attempt i was really happy with
it because when you are doing it and
you're so close with it it doesn't look
like much but when you step back and
look at that in its entirety after that
obviously you had to make some of that
burger secret sauce that you spit on the
bun it's really simple mayo ketchup
mustard a little bit of pickle juice
i really enjoyed making this one it was
just really fun adventure i thought it
looked beautiful and was able to
surprise my good friend victor with it
and he was super crazy about it that is
the adventure of a 30 pound breaker
i'm alexis and i'm going to make a
classic diner style burger with pickled
red onions and homemade aioli to make
the pickled bread onions i'm going to
bring apple cider vinegar sugar and salt
to a boil remove it from the heat add
the onions and let it sit for an hour at
room temperature while the onions are
pickling i'm going to make my aioli you
add an egg yolk dijon mustard garlic
whisk them together and then i'm slowly
going to add the olive oil until it
begins to emulsify and at the end it
should be thick and creamy once you add
the lemon juice the aioli will become
paler in color salt to taste aioli will
keep up for two days in the fridge but
after that you want to throw it away i'm
going to butter the buns with melted
butter and then put them under the
broiler for a minute and a half so they
just get just a little toasted for diner
style burgers and you just want to take
about a four ounce piece of ground beef
roughly shape it into a mound i think
like a glorified meatball i'm seasoning
the meat with salt and pepper and then
i'm going to get the cast iron really
hot a little bit of oil and then i'm
going to add the
meat mounds and then immediately smash
it down with a spatula
diner style patties cook really quickly
it should be about two to three minutes
on this side as soon as i flip the
burger i'm adding the cheddar cheese by
the time the cheddar cheese has melted
the burger should be done cooking it's
got the perfect combination of pickles
from the red onions it's got that creamy
aioli to go with the really juicy meat
and then melted cheese a thin diner
style patty is classic all-american and
it's really easy to make at home i just
made my dream burger
[Music]
[Music]
you